it seems that memory is random some
things we recall better than others it's
probably not random it's just that we
don't always understand what makes one
experience more memorable than another
one way to wrap your head around this is
to think about emotional memory anytime
we experience something in a heightened
emotional state we're more likely to
remember it for example most of us who
are baby boomers remember exactly what
was happening to them the day that
President Kennedy was shot but it's
unlikely that we remember what was going
on the week before or the week after so
there are experiences that taint or
exaggerate certain memories that make
them fix into our memory stores better
than others
to be malleable that is they seem to
change over time and I've had the
experience i'm sure many of us have had
the experience where we go back to a
place and we're convinced that it's on
the other side of the street or there's
something different about it and yet
that hadn't occurred and what happens is
that memory is basically stored in
little neurochemical packets in the
brain and there are a lot of
physiological processes that can affect
those neural chemical packets so they
can be changed and our memories can
deceive us very often